[Musique]
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et réussir notre transition
énergétique il faut rénover nos
bâtiments il y a urgence bonobazin
bonjour bonjour directeur général de
Saint-Gobain c'est l'un de vos combats
cette performance énergétique des
bâtiments c'est vraiment l'un des
dossiers prioritaires pour sauver la
planète pardon de le dire comme ça
les bâtiments représentent de par le
monde plus de 40% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donc c'est très important
pour l'urgence climatique de rénover les
bâtiments mais c'est aussi important
pour l'urgence énergétique à laquelle on
fait face en Europe en France et aussi
pour l'urgence sociale de pouvoir bien
se loger bien se chauffer dans son
bâtiment donc c'est aussi bon pour le
portefeuille des Français c'est très
important
c'est très important pour le pouvoir
d'achat on voit les factures
énergétiques montées une bonne
rénovation d'une maison individuelle on
peut diviser par 5 ou 6 la facture
énergétique de sa maison enfin ce qui
plaît pour la rénovation énergétique
j'ai envie de dire maintenant tout de
suite et pas et pas demain ou dans 10
ans il y a cette question de la
souveraineté énergétique c'est vrai que
44% de l'énergie dépensait en France
cette énergie dans les bâtiments publics
ou privés si on la baisse de 10% on
économie 6 ou 7 tranches nucléaire et se
donner l'énergie qu'on ne va pas acheter
autrefois en Russie aujourd'hui au Qatar
aux États-Unis donc il faut retrouver de
la souveraineté en baissant la
consommation énergétique des bâtiments
CQFD bon maintenant pour celles et ceux
qui nous regardent qui disent de quoi
est-ce que il parle c'est de là cette
rénovation thermique à quoi ça ressemble
est-ce que parce que certains se disent
bah on fonctionne au coup parcours
certains vont changer une fenêtre
installé une pompe à chaleur pour vous
j'ai envie de dire c'est tout ce qu'il
ne faut pas faire faire du coup par coup
ça vous arrange aussi vous me direz en
même temps la meilleure énergie c'est ça
le compte dépense pas si vous pensez à
votre maison comme un cube il faut aller
vers de la rénovation globale plusieurs
gestes pas uniquement monogestes
plusieurs gestes une sorte de passeport
du bâtiment comme un carnet de
vaccination alors il faut isoler les
murs les fenêtres le toit les combles ou
le toit changer aussi le système de
chauffage quand vous avez isolé les murs
les fenêtres le toit vous avez fait à
peu près 60 ou 70% du chemin et ensuite
vous pouvez passer sur un système de
chauffage moderne donc installer une
pompe à chaleur sans avoir renforcé
encore une fois isoler les fenêtres les
murs c'est de l'énergie vous allez
chauffer les oiseaux à l'extérieur ou
sur le toit c'est un peu comme rouler
avec votre voiture climatisation à fond
les fenêtres ouvertes donc il faut bien
isoler le bâti et après la pompe à
chaleur sera efficace donc il faut faire
les choses dans le bon ordre l'enveloppe
finalement le bâtil la boîte et après à
l'intérieur vous mettez un système
moderne de chauffage sauf que sauf que
sauf que pour celles et ceux qui se
lancent dans cette rénovation globale il
y a un coût ça coûte cher et tout le
monde n'a pas les moyens il y a un
forfait global de ma prime rénov qui
existe il a été d'ailleurs un petit peu
réhaussé mais il est largement
insuffisant d'accord alors il faut
cibler les bâtiments qu'on appelle FG
c'est à dire vraiment les passoires
énergétiques moi ce que j'appelle de mes
vœux c'est vraiment en disant éradiquer
les 5 millions de passoire énergétique
et pour ça effectivement limiter le
reste à charge des ménages à revenus
modestes pour que le coût pour eux dans
leur porte-monnaie soit plus faible et
qui puisse engager cette rénovation qui
va apporter des économies de factures
énergétiques donc si on fait une
rénovation intelligente on va être sur
200 300 euros du mètre carré on peut
avoir beaucoup plus de soutien de la
prime rénove pour les passoires
énergétiques ou les revenus modestes
c'est combien aujourd'hui ça prend
combien en charge à peu près ma prime
rénov ça va prendre 10 à 15 % sur une
rénovation de maison individuelle le
compte n'est pas il faut c'est pourquoi
je plaise il faut faire x 4 ou X5 sur
les gestes 5 milliards c'est 2 milliards
et demi déjà chaque année dans les
contes de l'État mais alors prenez la
facture du bouclier énergétique ça a été
50 milliards tout le monde n'a pas
besoin d'un bouclier énergétique sur sa
facture d'électricité ou de gaz il y a
des ménages qui ont besoin encore plus
que ce qu'ils ont reçu si on prenait 10
milliards des 50 milliards de la facture
analgétique et qu'on les met sur la
prime manœuvre on fait x 5 sur la prima
neuve et à ce moment-là vous baissez le
reste à charge des ménages qui ont
vraiment besoin parce qu'ils sont en
précarité énergétique de rénover leur
bâtiment ils auraient un reste à charge
très faible et il passerait d'une
passoire g à un bâtiment et donc c'est
moins de factures énergétiques et une
revalorisation patrimoniale de leur bien
reste à charge qui serait de combien si
en quadruple
au lieu d'avoir 10 à 20% de soutien on
aurait 80 70 80 % et donc la charge de
20 30 % et donc ce serait tout à fait
accessible et j'ai oublié de vous parler
des matériaux innovants c'est un sujet
j'imagine aussi performant innovant pour
rénover de façon optimale tout en étant
évidemment éco-responsable et durable
c'est aussi un grand défi pour
l'industrie aujourd'hui pour vous aussi
la bonne nouvelle dans le bâtiment c'est
que les solutions techniques existent
faire une maison passive à Angers à
Grenoble on sait faire une maison
passive nous plaisons passive
c'est-à-dire qu'une maison qui
consomerait moins d'énergie qu'elle n'en
produit avec des cellules
photovoltaïques sur le toit avec tout un
tas de systèmes de très bonnes isolation
donc faire un bâtiment très très
performant on sait faire avec toutes les
solutions techniques qui aujourd'hui
existent après accessible après
accessible la question c'est de
s'engager à grande échelle pour à la
fois créer tous les emplois qu'on évoque
tout à l'heure et deuxièmement que les
industriels fournissent leur capacité
donc il y a des isolants de très bonne
qualité nous on vient de lancer par
exemple un nouveau double vitrage qui
allie une transmission lumineuse accrue
du confort d'été confort solaire parce
qu'il y a une question maintenant des
pics de température l'été et du confort
thermique l'hiver donc il y a tout un
tas de solutions avançons avec plus
d'incitations publiques et aussi du
travail sur les bâtiments publics et
avec aussi des financements et c'est le
rôle des banques qui selon vous un rôle
clé à jouer pour réussir ce défi et
selon vous elles ne prennent pas assez
de risques elles doivent plus
s'impliquer aux côtés des ménages c'est
une question qu'on doit se poser en
France quand vous empruntez
de votre âge de votre profession et de
votre état de santé elle ne se préoccupe
pas du bâti est-ce que c'est un bâti qui
thermiquement des pas bon est-ce qu'il
faut le rénover est-ce qu'il est AB ou g
dans le diagnostic de performance
énergétique moi je pense que c'est
important d'intéresser le monde bancaire
qui est un élément essentiel de notre
l'économie à l'efficacité énergétique du
bâtiment public ou privé vous avez
aujourd'hui les banquiers vous disent
que la limite c'est la capacité
d'endettement il faut pas que ça dépasse
30 % des revenus du ménage donc pour
dire 30% c'est bien mais rajouter et ça
c'est l'État qui le décide à ajouter 3 4
ou 5 % pour l'efficacité énergétique du
bâtiment parce que ça améliorera la
capacité de remboursement de
l'emprunteur du ménage dans sa maison
qui perd à moins de factures et donc il
y aura plus de pouvoir d'achat donc on
pourrait très bien dire voilà la règle
stricte tous un suc classique sur
l'emprunt et voilà le surcroît que vous
pouvez financer pour la rénovation
énergétique ce qui améliorera le
bâtiment et donc l'hypothèque si vous
preniez une hypothèque sur le bâtiment
mais surtout la capacité de
remboursement du ménage ça améliorera
son confort de vie il sera moins absent
au travail et c'est d'être à plus
heureux c'est vertueux c'est tout à fait
vertueux s'agissant des de la rénovation
fini là-dessus des bâtiments publics
vous plaidez pour s'attaquer d'abord en
premier lieu aux écoles s'en a entendu
et aux hôpitaux pourquoi cela en premier
en termes de bâti en public quand on
regarde les bâtiments publics en fait
70% d'entre eux ce sont les
établissements de santé au sens large et
les établissements d'éducation donc
traiter ces deux domaines là vous
traitez 70% des bâtiments publics et de
surcroît ce sont quand même des univers
exigeants en termes de profession quand
vous êtes infirmier quand vous êtes
médecin aide-soignant brancardier dans
un hôpital sur des services de
réanimation on l'a vu pendant le covid
quand vous êtes enseignant dans une
salle de classe ce sont des professions
exigentes donc apporter un bien-être au
travail ça peut être la qualité
acoustique d'une salle de classe qui
fait que l'enseignant n'aura pas assez
gosier monter sa voix que l'enfant au
quatrième rang entendra mieux donc tout
ça ça participe d'une meilleure
éducation aujourd'hui rénover une école
vous avez un retour sur investissement
en quatre ou cinq ans parce que votre
facture énergétique ça n'est plus
l'argent perdu et au bout de 4 ou 5 ans
vous rentrez dans votre argent dans
votre investissement mais il faut et
c'est pour ça que la logique du tiers
financement est intéressante c'est
raisonner plus ryanuelle sortir de la
logique annuelle de la comptabilité
publique et se dire qu'au bout de quatre
cinq ans vous avez réduit vos frais de
fonctionnement vous avez investi et vous
transmettez ça aux nouvelles générations
ce chantier de la rénovation énergétique
c'est un chantier titanesque il faut que
accéléré c'est prioritaire et nous
sommes prêts bon merci en tout cas merci
à vous Bruno Bazin directeur général de
Saint-Gobain merci merci